[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mardi 18 avril voici le programme de
ce soir trois jours après la
promulgation de la réforme des retraites
le président de la République s'est
exprimé hier soir à 20h pour tenter
d'apaiser les tensions et relancer son
quinquennat une intervention de 13
minutes durant laquelle le chef de
l'État n'a pas fait de grandes annonces
mais à fixer son programme d'ici le 14
juillet suite à son allocution la Polito
économiste Véronique Jérôme fait le
point sur ce qu'il faut retenir dans
cette émission également la réaction des
élus yvelinois issus de différents
partis politiques trois minutes pour
convaincre voici le but de la troisième
édition du concours d'éloquence organisé
par le département des Yvelines au total
14 collèges se sont affrontés ce matin à
l'espace juste de plaisir au travers de
joutes oratoires le thème l'alimentation
gaspillage trouble alimentaire ou encore
art culinaire plusieurs trophées ont été
remis à l'issue du concours les
résultats dans cette émission enfin si
je vous dis qu'il sera bientôt possible
de se replonger dans l'époque médiévale
découverte de la calligraphie de la
broderie ou encore de la teinture
plusieurs animations et démonstrations
sont organisées ce week-end au château
de la Madeleine au cœur de la Vallée de
Chevreuse on en parle avec Joséphine
colmarger la vice-présidente déléguée à
la Culture pour le département et
justement elle se trouve en plateau avec
nous ce soir Joséphine Colmas berger
bonsoir bonsoir alors au programme 4
weekends au château de la Madeleine pour
se replonger dans l'époque médiévale
quel est l'objectif de cet événement
remettre au goût du jour remettre en
avant cet événement historique cette ce
lieu historique
qui mérite véritablement je dirais de
d'être redynamisé parce que c'est vrai
que c'est un lieu très important en
Île-de-France c'est pas uniquement au
niveau départemental et donc on aura
l'occasion d'en parler un peu plus en
détail tout à l'heure dans notre partie
culture dans cette particulture nous
parlons également de théâtre le Comité
Départemental d'animation et de théâtre
amateurs des Yvelines plus communément
dénommé codative et organise la première
édition de la nacelle ADL votre
rendez-vous avec le théâtre au féminin
pour en parler avec nous François
Jolivet bonsoir alors vous êtes le
président du codative alors avant de
parler de ce rendez-vous la nacelle à
des ailes est-ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter ce que c'est kodative c'est le
comité qui fait derrière la cinquantaine
de troupes et Vinois le plus important
au niveau de l'Île-de-France on a
environ 700 comédiens et
les troupes irlinoises qui se projettent
au niveau de l'Île-de-France et de la
France entière donne environ 250
représentations par an de théâtre dans
tous les lieux voilà et donc là ce
samedi vous organisez la première
édition de la nacelle à des ailes
à l'honneur et donc on aura aussi
l'occasion d'en parler un peu plus en
détail tout à l'heure et enfin avec nous
sur le plateau une journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 c'est ninja bonsoir
bonsoir dans quelques instants vous
allez nous présenter les informations du
jour dans les Yvelines dans cette
émission également la proposition de loi
sur les logements déposés par le député
de la nupes William Martinez le portrait
d'une plaisir Oise espoir de la
gymnastique pour Paris 2024 et puis
comme chaque mardi les insolites de
Véronique ithurbit ces informations
originales qui vous ont peut-être
échappé dans les Yvelines mais avant
tout ça je vous je vous propose de jeter
un coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
le printemps est le soleil reviennent
dans les Yvelines demain matin le ciel
sera dégagé sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera 10 degrés en moyenne dans
l'après-midi le soleil continuera de
briller et le thermomètre va encore
monter il fera 18 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Rambouillet
et 17 degrés dans le secteur de
Versailles et demain nous fêterons la
sainte Emma le point maintenant sur
l'actualité dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Céline Charles
on en parlait en début d'émission le
chef de l'État s'est exprimé hier à 20h
trois jours après la promulgation de la
réforme des retraites tout à fait une
allocution de 13 minutes dans laquelle
Emmanuel Macron revient d'abord
logiquement sur la réforme des retraites
une réforme nécessaire pour le président
qui regrette néanmoins l'absence de
consensus il souhaite maintenant tourner
la page et face à la colère de cette
derniers mois elle s'est donné 100 jours
pour mener un plan d'apaisement et
d'action autour de trois chantiers
prioritaires le premier consacré au
travail il sera notamment question de
revenus de conditions de travail de
carrière le deuxième concerne la justice
avec l'annonce par exemple de la
création de 200 nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie enfin le chef de l'État
entendre travailler sur le progrès
notamment sur des sujets liés à
l'éducation et la santé il a donné
rendez-vous aux Français le 14 juillet
pour un premier bilan on écoute les
réactions de plusieurs élus c'était une
allocution nécessaire après tout ce
débat autour de la des retraites qui a
été un débat long important aussi pour
nos concitoyens mais aussi montrer que
en dehors de cette réforme des retraites
il y avait d'autres projets qu'on était
mener et qui permettait aussi de
poursuivre la transformation du pays
quand on arrive à travailler ensemble
maintenant la main on arrive à des bons
résultats présidents à rappeler hier les
résultats notamment économiques du pays
qui fait qu'on a jamais créé autant
d'emploi j'aimerais ouvrir autant de
sites industriels qu'on est le pays le
plus attractif d'Europe et tout ça c'est
grâce aussi au travail de tous pas de
surprise il y avait beaucoup de
condescendance et de mépris dans
l'intervention du président de la
République qui a décrété qu'on passait à
autre chose sauf que les Françaises et
les Français ne veulent pas passer à
autre chose et que le sujet de cette
réforme des retraites il reste entier et
que la volonté d'abrogation de cette
réforme désormais promulguée reste
entier donc c'est pas au président de la
République qui n'est que président de la
République de choisir ce que les gens
ont dans la tête je pense que les
Français avaient assez peu d'atteintes
et répondre la colère qui est palpable
clairement dans nos rues par un circulé
il y a rien à voir
c'est assumer c'est comme ça le déva est
fini et d'une extrême violence en fait
ça rajoute que de la violence à la
violence qui était existe déjà dans
notre quotidien et je pense que ça ne
fait que bah acter la déconnexion d'un
président qui regarde mais alors qui
regarde vers quelle direction
Guillaume quérou le président de la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie des
Yvelines a annoncé aujourd'hui sa
candidature à la présidence du Ménès du
Medef au niveau national oui alors que
le président Emmanuel Macron recevait le
patronat à l'Elysée ce matin Guillaume
Kerrou s'est déclaré candidat à la
succession de Geoffroy Roux de Bézieux à
la présidente du Medef un Medef qu'il
souhaite entreprenant et plus moderne
parmi certaines de ses positions une
parité parfaite et davantage d'autonomie
aux fédérations professionnelles et au
Medef territoriaux pour recréer un Medef
de terrain originaire du Mantois
Guillaume quero a plusieurs casquettes
dirigeant de l'entreprise didactis
depuis 20 ans administrateur du Medef
Yvelines président du club des
entrepreneurs et président de la Chambre
de commerce et d'industrie des Yvelines
le candidat doit maintenant recueillir
les 150 parrainages nécessaires pour
pouvoir se présenter à l'élection
scrutin qui aura lieu le 6 juillet
prochain le département des Yvelines a
dévoilé aujourd'hui sa première campagne
pour valoriser les sites et disciplines
olympiques dans les Yvelines une matière
dont on peut le voir sur les trois
visuel qui s'affiche à l'écran c'est
s'affiche ont été dévoilées par le
département pour représenter les sites
et épreuves olympiques qui se
dérouleront dans notre département pour
les Jeux Olympiques de 2024 que comme
vous le savez les Yvelines accueilleront
8 disciplines olympique et de
paralympiques on retrouve les Scream le
golfe l'équitation le VTT ou le cyclisme
disait preuve dans 5 sites d'accueil le
vélo drone et le Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines le château de
Versailles la colline d'Élancourt et
certaines routes de la Vallée de
Chevreuse le département des Yvelines a
d'ailleurs adopté en 2022 un dispositif
d'accompagnement de 10 millions d'euros
dédiés aux subventions des centres de
préparation des JO sur le territoire
enfin gare aux allergies si vous êtes
sensibles au pollen en ce début de
printemps mieux vaut prendre vos
précautions le Réseau National de
Surveillance Aérobiologique a classé le
département en impact sanitaire élevé
attention notamment au boulot c'est
l'arbre qui a le plus d'impact dans les
Yvelines la pluie prévue en fin de
semaine devrait cependant vous apaiser
merci beaucoup c'est ninja pour toutes
ces informations et courage à ceux qui
ont des allergies et comme d'habitude si
vous aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager en utilisant le hashtag 78 news
suite à l'allocation du président de la
République hier soir à 20h la Polito
économiste Véronique Jérôme revient sur
les points abordés par Emmanuel Macron
et se demande si la France est encore
réformable aujourd'hui écoutez
[Musique]
les intentions ne suffiront pas on peut
décréter les réformes mais pas leurs
résultats une nécessité tant de choc on
meurtrit le pays choc structurel de la
démondialisation choc conjoncturelle
énergétique inflationniste hausse des
taux d'intérêt et de la charge de la
dette publique comme privée à qui la
faute au marché ou à l'état et sa
bureaucratie quelle solution une
intervention de l'État ou plus de
liberté pour le marché c'est aux
politiques que revient le choix des
armes et des réformes Emmanuel Macron
classé centriste a déjà déclenché des
réformes qui penchent à droite réforme
de l'assurance chômage ou qui penche à
gauche avec le bouclier anti-inflation
néanmoins pour l'analyse politique ou
économique le politique décide toujours
sous contrainte une correction des
déséquilibres économiques imposent de
cibler entre des perdants qui financent
la mesure et des gagnants qui en
profiteront mais pour financer
l'augmentation de ces dépenses publiques
déjà insoutenables à 57% du PIB sans
augmenter aujourd'hui les impôts on va
creuser aussi le déficit et avec lui la
dette publique que des générations
futures devront assumer
pour l'heure quelques pistes ont été
dévoilées par Emmanuel Macron loi
travail déclinée dans un grand chantier
pouvoir d'achat parce que l'inflation et
le sujet numéro 1 qui attise la colère
de la rue pas de réformes ici mais
mettre chacun face à ses responsabilités
consultation des partenaires sociaux pas
trop dans les syndicats peuvent aussi
s'entendre comme ils l'ont démontré lors
de l'accord sur le partage de la valeur
mais on peut souligner un paradoxe ici
d'une situation budgétaire quasi
insoutenable comme le démontre la Cour
des comptes qui plaide plutôt
implicitement pour une politique de
rigueur tandis que le politique fantasme
sur la lutte contre l'inflation comme
plus facilement négociable car aussi
délégable au risque d'une boucle prix
salaire infinie contre-productive
s'agissant des réformes structurelles de
long terme l'État semble s'engager
explicitement dans une réforme de
réindustrialisation pour une industrie
verte il devra aussi s'inquiéter de
l'hôpital la justice l'éducation les
transports mais il lui faudra alors
prendre la vraie mesure du coût
bureaucratique usé de medgemark pour
améliorer la performance des services
publics et plus tard peut-être reste les
marqueurs pour l'histoire loi
immigration comptant sur l'apport des
voix de LR ou encore la réforme des
institutions
réformer n'est pas si simple
paradoxalement la paix sociale s'obtient
par des réformes consensuelles mais
elles sont aussi peu agissantes à la
correction des déséquilibres tandis
qu'il est impossible de guérir
l'économie sans la brutalité de réforme
structurelles fortes vraie dilemme car
lorsque les tailles fort et nous
oppressent lorsqu'il est faible nous
périssons disait Paul Valéry la mère des
réformes ne passerait-elle pas alors par
an audit généralisé du fonctionnement de
l'État aux politiques de relever les
défis réveiller cette puissance endormie
que la France engageant des actions dans
un volontarisme politique hors de tout
calcul électoraliste et d'observer
parfois que ce qui est salutaire à la
nation ne va pas semblable dans
l'opinion ni sans perte dans l'élection
telles étaient les dernières phrases du
général de Gaulle dans mémoire d'espoir
[Musique]
avec la crise énergétique les locataires
ont vu leur charge exploser cet hiver
certains ont de plus en plus de
difficultés à payer leur loyer et
factures conséquences en un an les
impayés dans les logements sociaux ont
augmenté de 10%, c'est dans ce contexte
que le député lui pèse de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines William
Martinet vient de déposer une
proposition de loi elle vise à prendre
des mesures d'urgence pour protéger les
locataires de la hausse des loyers et
des charges les lui a présenté son texte
à des associations de locataires
vendredi 14 avril à Fontenay-le-Fleury
les précisions de Grégory canalet et
Julien lol le roi
William Martinet bonsoir bonsoir député
dupez de la onzième circonscription des
Yvelines nous est déposé pour votre
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi visant à prendre des
mesures d'urgence pour protéger les
locataires de la hausse des loyers et
des charges on rappelle juste le
contexte la fin de la trêve hivernale
est intervenue le 31 mars dernier avec
des Français on le rappelle toucher par
un contexte économique contraint cette
crise énergétique notamment l'inflation
pourquoi avoir déposé cette proposition
de loi à vos yeux aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ne va pas assez loin avec
la mise en place de son bouclier
tarifaire et le gel de l'indice de
référence des loyers jusqu'en juin
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que le
renchérissement du prix du logement est
une véritable bombe sociale et
l'objectif de ma proposition de loi
c'est d'apporter des solutions pour
réussir à la désamorcer puisque le
problème du coût du logement c'est un
problème ancien il s'agit pas dire que
il date seulement dit à quelques mois
mais dernièrement il y a eu plusieurs
décisions du gouvernement plusieurs
éléments de contexte qui ont fait que
subitement le prix du logement c'est
renchéri donc il y a une décision du
gouvernement qui est particulièrement
regrettable c'est celui en juillet
dernier d'avoir décidé de d'augmenter
l'IRL l'indice de référence des loyers
de 3,5%. donc cela permet en cours de
bail qu'un bailleur décide d'augmenter
de 3,5% les loyers c'est un chiffre
historique
exactement c'est ça c'est vraiment parle
de locataire qui ont déjà signé un bail
et qui reçoivent un courrier de leur
bailleur disant ça va être à partir de
maintenant 3,5% plus cher donc ça c'est
un premier problème et deuxième problème
que nous avons et qui concerne beaucoup
d'habitants de ma circonscription c'est
celui du renchérissement du prix des
charges parce que vous savez que il y a
actuellement une crise sur le marché de
l'énergie qui fait que l'électricité le
gaz coûte beaucoup plus cher et les
bailleurs sociaux et aussi les
copropriétés n'ont pas accès aux tarif
réglementés de l'énergie donc quand les
prix sur le marché exposent ils doivent
répercuter ça sur les charges qui sont
facturées au locataire et moi j'ai pu
constater si je ne parle que des
bailleurs sociaux de locataires de
séquences de résidence Yvelines Essonne
de Valophis donc là on parle de
plusieurs villes de la circonscription à
qui le bailleur a annoncé plus 50 + 100
+ 150 euros de charges tous les mois je
parle pas d'une régularisation de
Charles je parle d'un prix qui augmente
tous les mois et ça ça met des familles
dans une détresse sociale vraiment
vraiment terrible donc l'idée de la
proposition de loi c'est d'intervenir
sur ces deux principaux sujets de dire
on revient sur l'augmentation de l'IRL
qui a été décidée par le gouvernement
parce que c'était une mauvaise mesure et
deuxième proposition c'est de dire on
bloque les prix de l'énergie y compris
pour les bailleurs et les copropriétés
pour éviter cette explosion des charges
et vous avez cette proposition de loi ce
14 avril à Fontenay-le-Fleury a des
associations de locataires on va voir ce
qu'ils pensent d'une telle proposition
de loi on est tout à fait d'accord avec
les propositions qui sont faites compte
tenues que nous on est vraiment sur le
terrain et on peut vous confirmer que
c'est une nécessité il y a des appels
énormes sur les locataires
et ça passe très mal ça passe très très
mal parce que c'est le pouvoir achat les
locataires qui touche là parce que nous
la série on avait déjà demandé c'est que
la part des charges
au niveau de la location logement soit
plus importante parce que la location
logement actuellement
à 95% quoi c'est sur le loyer mais le
loyer bouge moins finalement que les
charges quand vous je sais pas si vous
avez vu mais sur certaines résidences
les gens ils sont 150 euros
d'augmentation par mois de charges
vous le disiez vous avez eu écho de
quelques situations alarmantes et
notamment pour des locataires qui
habitent la onzième circonscription des
Yvelines c'est peut-être aussi ce qui a
nourri votre réflexion sur ce projet de
loi tout à fait même je peux aller plus
loin j'ai fait cette proposition de loi
de par les retours que j'ai eu des
habitants de la circonscription même
pour tout vous dire ça a commencé au
mois de juillet dernier j'étais au
quartier du Bois de l'étang à la
verrière et là il y a des locataires qui
sont venus me voir et qui m'ont dit
Monsieur le Député j'ai mes charges
locatives qui augmentent de 150 euros
par mois il y a même pour tout vous dire
quand les locataires m'ont dit ça la
première réponse que je leur ai fait
c'est peut-être que vous vous êtes
trompé 150 euros par mois vous confondez
avec une régularisation de charge et du
coup c'est locataire m'ont emmené le
courrier de leur bailleur donc en
l'occurrence c'est séquences le bailleur
qui a envoyé ce courrier et c'était bien
des augmentations de 150 euros par mois
donc j'ai pu mesurer cette détresse là
parce que derrière vous savez c'est des
familles surtout dans le logement social
qui ont des petits salaires ou des
petites retraites voilà à qui il y avait
peut-être 300 200 euros de reste à vivre
et si vous enlevez la
différents au logement et de protéger
les familles celles qui ont des
difficultés financières mais aussi les
autres parce que plus 3,5% de loyer et
des dizaines d'euros en plus pour les
charges ça frappe tout le monde même les
classes moyennes et c'est toujours un
problème alors vous avez commencé en
parler qu'est-ce que vous proposez
concrètement peut-être de baisser l'IRL
c'est à dire mais c'est peut-être les
loyers comment faire entendre à des
bailleurs qu'il faut baisser les loyers
aujourd'hui alors effectivement il y a
dans cette proposition loi une mesure
qui consiste à baisser l'IRL pour
finalement abroger la décision qui a été
prise par le gouvernement c'est vrai que
c'est un effort qui est demandé aux
propriétaires bailleurs mais la question
elle est très simple on est dans une
période de crise c'est difficile pour
pour tout le monde il y a un problème de
pouvoir d'achat les prix qui qui
explosent donc la question c'est à qui
doit-on demander des efforts dans cette
période et ce qu'on le demande au
locataire qui sont principalement des
salariés généralement modestes ou de
classe moyenne qui sont aussi beaucoup
des jeunes des étudiants est-ce que ça
veut qu'on demande l'effort ou est-ce
que c'est au propriétaire bailleurs moi
je pense que c'est plus raisonnable de
le demander aux propriétaires d'ailleurs
encore une fois l'effort qu'on demande
c'est juste de dire n'augmentez pas le
loyer c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
raisonnable on en est actuellement dans
le parcours législatif la loi est
déposée doit être encore validée c'est
ça aujourd'hui oui j'ai déposé cette loi
il faut que l'administration de
l'Assemblée nationale valide qu'elle
soit bien bien conforme ce qui je pense
ne posera pas de question par contre
après le vrai sujet c'est est-ce que
cette proposition loi sera mise à
l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée nationale
et ça ça dépend de ce qu'on appelle la
Conférence des présidents à l'Assemblée
nationale avec une majorité de députés
qui sont du côté des macronistes donc
pour l'instant je me fais pas d'illusion
sur le fait que c'est pas demain que
cette proposition de loi soit à l'ordre
du jour et en même temps et en même
temps je me dis que cette question de
l'augmentation des loyers et des charges
elle concerne tout toute la population
et du coup tous les députés sont
concernés quel que soit leur bord
politique parce que je sais que même
chez mes collègues macronistes où LR ou
modem ou je ne sais qui dans leur
circonscription ils ont des locataires
qui les sollicitent sur cette sur cette
situation donc j'espère que j'arriverai
à convaincre tout le monde et que
peut-être dans un élan transpartisan
face à l'urgence social cette loi elle
puisse être étudiée adoptée une question
très importante vous le dites vous
pensez que on peut débattre dans un
climat serein on sait que le climat
était tendu très dernièrement avec cette
réforme des retraites mais pourquoi
est-ce que le climat est tendu à cause
de la détresse sociale des gens voilà
tout simplement pourquoi est-ce que les
gens s'opposent avec vigueur à la
réforme des retraites parce que
travailler deux ans de plus c'est
quelque chose qui leur paraît qu'il leur
paraît très compliqué et donc là c'est
la même chose sur la question la
question du pouvoir d'achat il va bien
falloir un jour prendre à bras le corps
cette question du pouvoir d'achat
qu'est-ce qu'on voit maintenant c'est
que même dans les supermarchés on a des
antivols qui sont mis sur la viande
enfin je veux dire on est arrivé dans
quelque chose où l'inflation elle met
les gens dans une situation de grande
détresse donc il faut agir et quel est
un des principaux postes de dépenses des
français surtout ceux de région
parisienne parce qu'on a assez là qu'on
a le logement le plus cher bon bah c'est
payé son son loyer donc on résoudra pas
le problème du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'inflation si on s'attaque pas à ce
sujet des loyers qui sont trop chers
c'est ce que propose ma proposition de
loi merci William Martinet député de la
11e circonscription des Yvelines je le
rappelle vous venez de déposer donc une
proposition de loi visant à prendre des
mesures d'urgence pour protéger les
locataires de la hausse des loyers et
des charges
allez comme chaque mardi c'est l'heure
maintenant de passer à notre page
culturel
[Musique]
à l'occasion du concours d'éloquence
organisé par le département des Yvelines
ce matin 14 collèges se sont affrontés
sur la scène de l'Espace Coluche à
plaisir de l'argumentaire au débat en
duel les collégiens se sont exprimés sur
le thème de l'alimentation le reportage
de Régine ralech il est évident
est un patrimoine
[Applaudissements]
la culinaire est-il un patrimoine c'est
l'un des thèmes proposés aux élèves
participants au concours d'éloquence
organisé par le département des Yvelines
avec parfois un peu de stress mais
beaucoup de courage des élèves de 3e
sont montés sur scène devant 14 classes
à l'espace Coluche à plaisir ce mardi 18
avril j'avais l'impression de me sentir
au César c'est vraiment une vraie
expérience quoi c'est c'est vraiment
genre plein de bonheur et plein de ouais
de joie sur scène et comme la prise de
parole ne s'improvise pas sur plusieurs
mois les élèves ont été coachs à
plusieurs reprises par impro actif cette
association basée à Versailles délivre
des formations sur l'improvisation
théâtrale et sur la prise de parole en
public il y a toute une méthode pour
réussir une prise de parole c'est pas
acquis c'est pas comme ça ça tombe pas
du ciel et donc ça manque encore dans
l'école française se finalement cet
apprentissage de la méthodologie d'un
oral réussi c'est une super aventure
bien bien coacher par par les comédiens
d'impro actif et puis les enseignants
j'étais loin d'être seul on était toute
une équipe à donner des arguments aux
élèves pour que après ils arrivent à
monter leur intervention des collégiens
reconnaissants et ravis d'avoir pris la
parole devant une salle comble de 400
élèves je suis super contente d'être là
et d'avoir gagné mais grâce à l'aide
collectif parce que franchement 100
lettres de la classe ni professeur je
pense que j'aurais jamais gagné Gabriel
moque a remporté le trophée du meilleur
éloquent en duel et trois autres
trophées ont été remis le trophée du
meilleur éloquent en argumentaire pour
soumaya ou Bella le coup de cœur du
département pour Marie hems et enfin le
trophée de la classe lauréate a été
remis au collège Les Trois Moulins
alors Joséphine Coleman berger vous
étiez présente ce matin pour ce concours
d'éloquence qu'avez-vous pensé des
prestations de ces jeunes collégiens
j'ai trouvé extraordinaire c'est fou
parce que on sent tout le travail qui
est fait en préparation avec les
enseignants et puis c'est un travail de
groupe et ensuite il y en a un bien qui
est choisi pour aller sur scène il faut
du courage quand même là il y avait
pratiquement 600 élèves qui étaient là
dans le théâtre moi je suis à chaque
fois scotché j'avais eu ça déjà l'année
dernière à Saint-Cyr-l'École et donc
cette année j'étais ravi d'accueillir un
plaisir cette manifestation qui
finalement démontre que les jeunes sont
pas nos jeunes ne sont pas aussi
branchés réseau et sont vraiment dans
une ouverture de capacité très
importante attention vous avez de la
concurrence
oui ça demande du courage de s'exprimer
comme ça publiquement alors après
l'éloquence on reste un peu dans le
thème puisqu'on va parler de théâtre
samedi prochain le 22 avril le Comité
Départemental d'animation et de théâtre
am des Yvelines organisent la première
édition de la nacelle ADL votre
rendez-vous avec le théâtre féminin pour
en parler avec nous François Jolivet le
président du codative alors au programme
de cet après-midi trois pièces
contemporaines écrites par des femmes
quel est l'objectif de cet événement
François Jolivet de remettre en avant
les femmes
peu d'autrices sont programmées donc et
on a une majorité de comédiennes et donc
il nous a paru évident qu'il fallait
mettre en valeur les autrices féminines
et on a eu parallèlement une proposition
de d'une troupe qui pourra également des
adolescents et qui parlera du
harcèlement voilà donc l'idée est simple
et donc on a on a travaillé de en
collaboration avec la nacelle qui est
une programmation ambitieuse avec une
très belle équipe à sa tête pour avoir
des des pièces contemporaines sur des
thèmes sociétaux voilà et alors quelle
est la place des femmes dans le théâtre
aujourd'hui
alors c'est difficile pour un homme d'en
parler mais je pense qu'elle est
insuffisante on va prendre exemple très
simple seulement moins de 20 femmes ont
été dominium Molière et environ 20% des
textes joués sont des textes écrits par
des femmes je pense que c'est très
insuffisant que il y a pas il y a pas de
raison objectif
à ce faible tôt voilà et donc je pense
que le comité peut faire mieux et qu'il
se doit de faire mieux et d'être leader
en la matière voilà alors justement je
sais que Joséphine Colmas berger la
cause des femmes vous tient à coeur et
le théâtre également vous tient à cœur
vous pensez quoi de cette initiative je
trouve que c'est une très belle
initiative moi j'ai commencé le théâtre
et la mise en scène il y a plus de 25
ans et c'est vrai que on se comptait sur
les doigts d'une main les femmes qui
étaient metteur en scène à l'époque on
en faisait à chaque fois en disant oh là
là une femme metteur en scène bon j'ai
vu que ça a bien évolué j'en suis ravie
et puis ce genre d'initiative est quand
même très importante parce que ça permet
de véhiculer aussi toute une série de
sujets qui sont des sujets sensibles
difficile et que l'on traite toujours de
façon je dirais
dans la dans la dureté parce que
l'immédiateté des solides enfin des
problématiques fait que et là par le
biais du spectacle et du théâtre je
trouve que c'est très belle initiative
vraiment et qui est autant de d'artistes
amateurs qui se lancent là-dedans bravo
merci bravo vraiment on va essayer de
faire bien c'est l'occasion de mettre en
avant des femmes dans le théâtre mais
aussi de parler de récits de femmes à
travers quatre pièces vous l'avez dit
donc il y aura une première pièce
radium girls d'Anne-Sophie Nédélec dans
cette pièce on replonge en 1937
puisque c'est inspiré d'une histoire
vraie d'un drame qu'on connu des femmes
qui travaillent aux États-Unis et qui
ont été contaminés en
peignant des cadrans voilà et donc ça
parle de leur lutte et ça fait
effectivement évoluer la cause du
travail et la cause des femmes aux
États-Unis
il y aura une deuxième pièce on continue
dans la programmation plus loin que loin
on fait un saut dans le temps on est en
1961 et on se retrouve sur une île
perdue alors c'est une pièce
d'une autrice britannique très connue à
risque et a fait l'objet de 5
traductions
en français notamment par domicile
qui parle qui t'inspire d'une histoire
vraie qui est l'histoire des habitants
de l'île de Tristan lakuna qui ont
quitté leur petite île en 1961 pour
aller en Angleterre
parce que il y avait des risques
notamment liés à la présence d'un volcan
et ça ça parle beaucoup de choses sur la
condition féminine voilà c'est une pièce
différentes de la première et quant à la
dernière pièce ça sera une pièce plus
détente plus de détente qui écrit par un
collectif d'Autriche qui s'appellera et
pendant ce temps Simone Veil avec un jeu
de mots
qui est plus divertissante et qui
retrace d'une manière avec un peu
d'humour la condition féminine au cours
des 60 dernières années qui est joué par
une troupe de moules les mascaris plus
loin que loin sera joué par les balades
un peu Marly le Roi et le Razen girl par
une troupe de Villepreux les ailes la
compagnie des ailes et puis on a aussi à
16h30 un très beau travail qui est fait
par des adolescentes pour rendre mètre
78 qui est implanté à Verneuil et
Vernouillet qui viendra
parler avec des adolescents de la
question du harcèlement scolaire est un
sujet compliqué douloureux et on a au
niveau de du comité qui est
majoritairement féminin
voulu absolument programmer cette pièce
parce que ça nous paraît important de
traiter ce sujet voilà pourquoi ça vous
semble important de traiter
important et que c'est bien que les il
puisse être abordés par des adolescents
eux-mêmes et non pas par les adultes
c'est un beau travail qui est fait par
exemple et je tiens le souligner les
trois autres pièces sont aussi
d'excellentes factures rassurez-vous
l'entrée est libre et nous nous
permettrons de c'était une volonté aussi
de faire en sorte que l'entrée soit
libre et sans réservation pour attirer
et sensibiliser le plus de monde le plus
de monde possible merci de votre
de votre invitation sur ce plateau donc
on est dans tout le monde à venir et on
se permettra de passer un petit chapeau
à la fin parce que toutes ces opérations
donc on verra la générosité du public
présent voilà
et c'est important mais c'est vraiment
important qu'on puisse travailler sur un
secteur où il y a quand même moins de
troupes qu'ailleurs dans le département
et puis je dois souligner également que
nous avons un partenariat avec une
association qui s'appelle woman safe
inchill run qui est implanté à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui s'occupe des
difficultés qui d'ailleurs dans les
locaux du département c'est
l'association d'écoute et
d'accompagnement pour les enfants et les
femmes victimes de violence possibilité
on aura de l'information et donc le
public pourra s'il le souhaite faire des
dons auprès de cette association voilà
et bien merci beaucoup François Jolivet
d'avoir répondu à toutes nos questions
je le rappelle donc la première édition
de lanacel Adel votre rendez-vous avec
le théâtre au féminin c'est samedi
prochain de 14h30 à 23h l'entrée est
libre et vous n'avez pas besoin de
réservation ça se passe au Théâtre de la
nacelle à Aubergenville un autre
rendez-vous est à ne pas manquer ce
week-end le département des Yvelines
inaugure les rendez-vous de la Madeleine
ça se passe comme son nom l'indique au
château de la Madeleine au cœur de la
vallée de Chev au programme 4 weekends
sur la vie à l'époque médiévale pour en
parler avec nous Joséphine Coleman
berger alors ce week-end ça commence
avec le thème de l'artisanat plusieurs
animations et ateliers sont au programme
comme la calligraphie et la broderie oui
tout à fait c'est-à-dire que celui
emblématique puisque comme je l'évoquais
rapidement tout à l'heure c'est quand
même un lieu qui était un site fortifié
médiéval le plus beau de l'Île-de-France
et qui et qui a maintenu vraiment ce
côté médiéval sans réhabilitation et il
était important que l'on puisse attirer
aussi un public familial parce que c'est
le but quand même c'est essayer de faire
quelque chose
d'intergénérationnel et donc on a choisi
de faire sur plusieurs weekends et bien
ce que l'on sait à peu près de du monde
de médiéval et là vous l'avez dit
effectivement sur l'artisanat et bien on
va pouvoir aussi nous apprendre un petit
peu ce qui se faisait à l'époque et
c'est plutôt intéressant parce que les
enfants les adultes tout le monde va y
trouver quelque chose d'un lieu très
important sur notre département que le
département vous savez en a fait
l'acquisition en 1981 et nous souhaitons
justement développer tout ça on a
quelques petites problématiques si je
peux me permettre c'est que c'est pas un
lieu qui peut accueillir énormément de
monde puisque il y a pas un parking
énorme mais par contre c'est un lieu
magique dans lequel aujourd'hui le
département a déjà fait pas mal de
travaux de réhabilitation et
d'investissement et nous nous faisons là
justement le mois d'avril le mois de mai
et puis aussi à l'automne nous allons
faire pas mal d'animations tours qui
tournent autour du monde médiéval avec
des costumes avec même des dégustations
donc je pense que ça va être intéressant
ce sera concrètement il y aura un vrai
village médiéval avec des stands on est
vraiment immergé dans dans tous les
compagnies qui sont invitées sont des
compagnies qui ont cette compétence et
qui savent particulièrement bien vous
remettre dans cette ambiance donc ce que
l'on souhaite à terme peut-être on
demandera au spectateur de venir aussi
habiller de cette façon-là ça pourrait
donner ça fait un peu de théâtre aussi
donc ce sont des compagnies théâtrales
de toute façon donc c'est vrai qu'on va
essayer d'immerger notre public le
public autour des comédiens dans ce
monde-là ce serait une bonne chose en
tout cas et justement ce premier weekend
il est animé par l'association Les
regrettiers d'histoire il est enfin
cette association est spécialisée dans
la reconstitution historique c'est ça
ils sont de même il est amour et ils ont
l'habitude de fonctionner dans de cette
façon là donc pour nous ça a pas été
très compliqué de les choisir parce
qu'on savait qu'ils avaient cette
spécialité on espère vraiment
attirer du monde je sais que ce château
est un château qui attire déjà parce que
il attire des personnes qui font des
treks qui se promènent dans toute notre
vallée de Chevreuse et on a aussi
énormément de tourisme sur le
département des Yvelines puisque c'est
en puissance depuis le covid tout le
monde me suis rendu compte que les
Yvelines c'est un poumon vert dans
lequel on peut vraiment venir à la fois
en balade à pied parce que on a des
forêts mais aussi à vélo et c'est vrai
que avoir des lieux comme ça comme des
maisons des illus c'est important donc
voilà les week-ends
complètement puisque les premières
découvertes que nous avons pu avoir ce
sont aussi des découvertes qui datent du
12e siècle puisqu'on a retrouvé des
céramiques on a retrouvé même un cadavre
de chien c'est pas pour être morbide
mais c'est pour vous dire que à l'époque
il faisait travailler aussi les chiens
sur les chantiers et on a aussi trouvé
des
fer à chevaux à cheval des fer à cheval
c'est mieux voilà même une gambarde on a
trouvé vous voyez c'est à dire que c'est
un lieu qui nous amène vraiment dans
cette époque là et ce qui ce qui est
superbe c'est que il n'y a pas eu de
réhabilitation ni à la Renaissance ni
plus tard et ce qui fait qu'il est resté
vraiment dans son jus médiéval donc
c'est c'est intéressant vraiment de
venir nous on espère au niveau des
départementales avec les réaménagements
que nous faisons sur les patrimoines et
la culture moi je m'occupe du Tourisme
et de la Culture au niveau du
département et bien on est une
association à la fois de réhabilitation
et d'activités culturelles pour pouvoir
faire venir du monde ça vous donne envie
d'y aller François Jolivet
je rappelais tout à l'heure que le le
théâtre
autour de l'an 1000 était
renaître à la faveur notamment de ce que
vous avez le drame liturgique qui est
puisque c'est la religion qui vers
l'ennui a réintroduit involontairement
le théâtre donc tout est lié entre le
médiéval et le théâtre on est pleinement
on est pleinement lié voilà et donc
c'est intéressant et le comité
préalablement avait effectivement
investi ces lieux avec grand plaisir
mais là pour le mois de juin nous nous
concentrerons sur théâtre à la ferme qui
est une autre
opérations
partenaires qui vont nous accueillir
dans des lieux où combien différents et
avec grand plaisir et donc on va pouvoir
lier les nourritures terrestres avec les
nourritures spirituelles
je vous pose aussi la question bonsoir
vous venez le soir parce que vous allez
nous présenter vos informations
insolites dans quelques instants mais du
coup vous aviez prévu au départ de nous
parler des rendez-vous de la Madeleine
dans vos informations mais oui je
suppose que ça vous donne envie d'y
aller complètement surtout que ce que
dit Madame c'est que on a l'impression
qu'on va on va y être et on va dire
directement plonger dans le moyen-âge
quoi pas de choses qui ont pollué c'est
c'est très intact tu imagines et je
crois que cette compagnie des regretti
rétractiez ça voulait dire quelque chose
mais je me suis un peu trop quoi c'est
pas les gens qui qui ramassent les
restes de nourriture et retraité
du Moyen-Âge exactement les races des
tables des nobles ou je sais pas quoi
elle a été redistribuée ou revendu voilà
donc ça ce sera pour le premier week-end
qui aura lieu bah là le 22 et le 23
avril et donc d'autres rendez-vous sont
à venir puisque à la fin du mois de mai
le thème ce sera sur la médecine en juin
c'est les armures et les épées qui sont
souvent les hommes voilà tout à fait en
octobre le château sera envahi par des
Vikings exactement on les attend pied
ferme
avec la compagnie du clan d'ivard
association qui est basée à benicourt
benicourt donc tout ça ce sont des
associations qui ont vraiment une
spécificité importante donc si vous
aimez les batailles un peu virulentes et
un peu viriles
médicinales mais bien sûr des visites
j'imagine ça va être la surprise voilà
les filtres oui on va rajeunir et même
les plus grands en relations de créer
leur propre déodorant
mais c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure dans toutes ces activités live
vraiment c'est pas uniquement venir et
regarder c'est venir agir participer
être vraiment acteur voilà de la
manifestation
et bien merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
si vous êtes intéressé les rendez-vous
de la Madeleine ça commence ce weekend
les 22 et 23 avril l'entrée est gratuite
allez comme chaque mardi on poursuit
avec vos insolites Véronique des
informations originales qui vous ont
peut-être échappé dans les Yvelines
et alors Véronique ce soir on commence
par le Mois Molière voilà c'est riche ce
printemps dans les Yvelines on va avoir
un petit peu de concurrence mais c'est
ça qui est bien quand les gens ont le
choix c'est génial alors moi je vais
vous parler donc du Mois Molière qui a
lieu pour la 27e édition au mois de juin
et je voulais vous faire un petit règle
qui retourne en arrière en fait ce
fameux mois Baudière donc il existe
depuis 27 ans il a été initié créé par
François Mazières qui était à l'époque
adjo
Omer Étienne peintre à Versailles il
était donc s'occupait de la culture et
il a eu l'idée de c'était un foot
théâtre c'est un foot théâtre François
mazzeri il a même pris des coups de
théâtre chez Marcel tu as son cours au
théâtre mon temps si imaginez-vous bref
et donc il a monté ce festival pour la
première fois en 1996 à l'époque c'était
Francis Perrin qui était le directeur du
montentier et il faudra aussi se faire
était sur une charrette avec sa troupe
et elle est haranguer enfin les foules
mais presque dans dans les rues de
Versailles comme comme Molière faisait
ou comme les troupes faisaient à
l'époque pour annoncer leur venue et
leur spectacle voilà donc ça et en fait
l'idée de françois de Mazières qui est
depuis 2008 maintenant maire de
Versailles et c'est de promouvoir le
renouveau des spectacles vivants
populaires de le privilégier les jeunes
compagnies il y en a beaucoup qui sont
résidences à Versailles et aussi de
comment dire et l'idée c'est aussi
d'aller vers le public d'aller dans tous
les quartiers d'aller chercher le public
et leur montrer que finalement c'est pas
que sérieux pas que sinistres enfin que
ça peut être drôle voilà c'était théâtre
et musique donc ça c'est dit et
qu'est-ce que ah oui et alors la force
de ce festival c'est qu'en fait c'est
quasiment tout le temps gratuit sauf
quelquefois 2 euros vous voyez ce qui
est pas énorme et je pense que c'est
aussi grâce à un nombre il y a une
centaine de bénévoles qui sont là depuis
le début et c'est ça qui fait la force
et qui permet ce système de gratuite et
pas de secret voilà les bénévoles c'est
dit donc après
des pièces elles vont souvent à Avignon
ou la même françois de Mazières va
chercher des pépites pour nous les
montrer l'année d'après voilà et
donc il y a 25 c'est la 27ème édition ça
fait juste trois fois que je le dis il y
A 330 représentations cette création
1000 comédiens musiciens 62 lieux donc
dans Versailles etc et 150000
spectateurs voilà donc
330 représentations est-ce que vous avez
repéré des temps forts Véronique comment
vous le savez Mathilde vous êtes trop
forts alors oui j'ai même un SCO ma
chère amie imaginez-vous que aujourd'hui
est sortie la programmation de ce fameux
Mois Molière donc il y a des temps forts
qui j'ai regardé ce qui est en premier
je me suis pas trop fouillé mais bon
vous n'avez pas attendre non plus ça va
être dans la cour des grandes écuries
qui a un lieu majestueux magique voilà
c'est super alors vous aurez par exemple
premier de juin
cogner une histoire africaine c'est une
création d'Eric Bouvron qui a été
nominée au Molière 2022 pour Laurence
d'Arabie et qui a eu un prix Molière du
théâtre privé pour cavalier en 2018 donc
voilà Joséphine Coleman berger je
connais très très bien
on parle tout un peu de musique
subsaharienne guerre contre les
braconniers un drame personnel donc ça
c'est le premier scoop après vous avez
si je relis la page d'avance il n'y a
pas Richard III alors Richard III de
William Shakespeare mis en scène est
jouée par William mezguiche qui est le
fils de son père donc on imagine qu'il a
de qui tenir ce jeune homme donc ça
c'est encore une de représentation après
vous avez la voix d'or ça vous parle
aussi d'Eric Bubu écrit par
thibault-dinières c'est deux vedettes de
la préguerre qui vit une histoire
d'amour passionnelle et déstrueux
destructrice pas déstructuré spectacle
musical et
et les conséquences de cette violence
amoureuse sur la famille vont vont être
montrés avec des reconstitutions
beaucoup de chansons et des souvenirs
etc et pour terminer les Fourberies de
Scapin quand j'étais
je connais pas bref mais après qu'elle
ne fut pas ma joie on regardant d'à peu
plus près alors s'il met en scène par
Anthony manier et parmi les acteurs de
cette création oui parce que j'ai pas
dit c'était des créations voilà vous
aurez les acteurs des mauvais élèves
cette compagnie originale que j'adore
avec Elisa Benito que j'ai déjà reçu en
VIP qui est la fille de Shirley Dino qui
les aident à mettre en scène et il y a
elle il y a Bérénice Caudry Anthony
Magnier et Valérian je sais plus et ils
sont juste extra franchement c'est
quelqu'un un peu réfractaire au théâtre
et un peu n'aime pas c'est son eux qu'il
faut voir quoi
je l'affirme haut et fort donc tout ça
au mois de juin
et pour votre deuxième information on
reste à Versailles et vous allez nous
parler esprit et jardin
le week-end prochain 22 23 avril donc
c'est la un événement pour les
passionnés de jardin c'est toute la
journée de 10 à 19h et c'est place de la
Cathédrale Saint Louis sur le parvis les
carrés Saint-Louis et au Potager du Roi
alors bon ça fait 15 ans que ça existe
il y a 70 exposants plein d'animations
etc il y a aussi des nouveautés pour
pour nous attirer en coréen encore ils
ont bien raison alors les nouveautés
qu'est-ce que ça va être un spectacle un
peu médiéval qui s'appelle les Oise
savante ça vaut pas cette compagnie dog
trainer en fait ils ont animé des fêtes
médiévales avec un troupeau d'oie 50
éducateur canin au départ et qui a un
peu bifurqué vers le dressage mais
gentil d'animaux donc ils ont leur chien
leurs oies leurs mouton et là il y aura
un spectacle les oies savantes ça fait
du moins que ça faut de l'organisation
il y a un chien c'est un chien qui va
les garder vous inquiétez pas
il y aura aussi alors une conférence de
Jean-Pierre Thauvin alors je le connais
il est passionnant ce monsieur c'est un
ordithologue qui manque de l'année
l'association naturaliste des Yvelines
et il a une propose une conférence sur
la place des oiseaux en ville et dans
les jardins et de ce qui reste comme
oiseau parce qu'il est référencé
donc voilà après vous aurez aussi une
découverte de Versailles cité-jardin on
vous emmènera faire une rando-conférence
avec des petites histoires sur des lieux
naturels comme le parc Balbi les étangs
Gobert des endroits où on va pas
forcément qu'on connaît pas forcément
l'allée des mortes mais la pièce de déçu
etc voilà il y aura un atelier de
décoration végétale un atelier de
tissage végétal un peu comme au
Moyen-Âge décidément excusez-moi je
préfère ma voix atelier de rempotage et
emprunte animale etc alors avec un coup
de cœur pour un événement enfin une
attraction qu'on a une activité comme on
dit je sais pas sur
les beaux arbres les beaux-arts
remarquables
parce que les arbres remarquables
doivent pour être répertoriés classés
comme arbre remarquable à votre corps
les beaux-arts ils sont beaux parce
qu'on les trouve beaux pointes à la
ligne voilà donc vous avez une appli sur
l'appli Versailles vous avez un parcours
qui ont mis en place justement pour le
salon esprit jardin mais qui qui est
fonctionne dès maintenant vous avez une
quinzaine d'arbres qui ont été
répertoriées comme veau et on vous fait
le l'itinéraire vous avez donc
différents arbres vous avez un petit
côté historique sur chaque arbre on vous
raconte une petite histoire et c'est
bien parce que on les voit pas forcément
alors par exemple vous avez les
cerisiers du Japon en fleur c'est
splendeur voilà ils sont très beaux
aussi en automne parce que les feuilles
sont des couleurs magnifiques vous avez
quoi d'autre comme magnifique arbres
beaux arbres
le cèdre du Liban de l'école des
konamine vous avez des
c'est quand même dingue d'avoir perdu
ses frais
en direct
du Japon
tout en bazar
c'est pas grave en tout cas esprit
jardin
donc tout ça esprit et jardin c'est ce
weekend
de ce soir si vous voulez my night by
night
[Rires]
on vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
comme d'habitude
le plaisir sera partagé allons poursuit
cette émission avec une petite page
sportive à présent
[Musique]
repérez en compétition en 2021 a tout
juste 15 ans Maelys la porte intègre
l'équipe de France de Gymnastique
Rythmique l'objectif pour la plaisir
Oise les Jeux Olympiques 2024 le
reportage de Gabriel Gontier
[Musique]
à 16 ans Maëlys la portrait de faire
partie de l'équipe qui représentera la
France en gymnastique rythmique aux JO
de Paris 2024
c'est Aline Seb qu'elle s'entraîne
depuis 2021
ce matin-là l'entraînement est dédié à
l'échauffement des lignes
en général donc avant de venir
entraînement on a deux heures de cours
donc ce matin on a eu échauffement des
lignes et après grand écart et là on va
passer à l'engin et on répète ça
l'après-midi deux heures de cours et
après entraînement de 16h30 à 20h
[Musique]
des journées intenses et des
entraînements rigoureux avec un objectif
concourir pour Paris 2024 j'aimerais
bien mais déjà titulaire ou à la limite
remplaçantes mais ce serait ça un rêve
parce que c'est à Paris c'est les jeux
en plus à Paris c'est une fierté de
pouvoir représenter la France à ses
côtés pour y parvenir ses entraîneurs
Anna baranova Sarah Bayonne et Grégory
MYLAN des pointures de la gymnastique
rythmique et de la danse à la carrière
internationale
[Musique]
selon eux malgré son jeune âge avec
beaucoup de travail Maelys à toutes ses
chances un jour de réaliser son rêve
olympique
[Musique]
nous voyons que Maëlys évolue beaucoup
elle peut devenir une bonne gymnaste en
équipe de France
mais je pense qu'à l'intégrera l'équipe
titulaire
oui
il travaille bien c'est une bonne
gymnaste avec de bonnes conditions et
elle s'intègre bien à l'ensemble
pour Maëlys intégrer un jour l'équipe de
France n'était pourtant pas une évidence
j'étais pas très forte à la base et puis
et puis j'ai travaillé et finalement il
y a eu un déclic un jour et
du coup on m'a repéré pour intégrer le
pôle
[Musique]
du travail et des sacrifices pour
atteindre l'excellence c'est à 14 ans
qu'elle quitte la maison familiale pour
la gymnastique un quotidien loin de ses
proches qu'elle retrouve tout de même
certains weekends
[Musique]
c'est chez elle que nous la retrouvons
quelques semaines plus tard bonjour on
se retrouve à plaisir sur un week-end de
repos après une semaine d'entraînement
un week-end auprès de sa famille qui
permet à la gymnase de redevenir une
adolescente presque comme les autres
pour quelques heures beaucoup de temps
surtout à mon repos donc je passe du
temps avec ma famille
on discute on regarde des films après on
peut regarder souvent du sport aussi on
regarde du foot tout ça après j'aime
bien me maquiller
dessiner de temps en temps voilà mais la
gymnastique n'est jamais très loin comme
en témoigne les photos et les nombreux
justaucorps ça c'était un de Mesut
préféré c'est petit dans ma première
année de Paul je crois
ces moments restent privilégiés pour la
famille qui se retrouve au complet pour
ses parents très investi dans sa
carrière voire Maëlys augio 2024 serait
une consécration si elle est sur ses
jeux de paris 2024 ce sera quoi votre
sentiment en bas de la fierté et puis
surtout surtout
une comment dire une joie de l'avoir
participé à un événement aussi énorme en
France en plus à la maison on pourra
aller la voir la voir défilé ou avoir
participé on a la chance de pouvoir voir
juste à côté donc c'est ça sera ça sera
un moment un événement génial quoi
pendant dans tous les cas vous allez
continuer de la suivre
même si c'était que Los Angeles ou des
choses en genre on irait quand même on
ira la voir il y a quand même des
événements faut pas rater
une fierté et un soutien important
maelyssa pour objectif d'intégrer
l'équipe titulaire ou remplaçante il lui
reste 15 mois pour atteindre son rêve
olympique
[Musique]
et vous la connaissez bien vous
Joséphine Colmas verger puisque elle
fait partie de fin c'est une plaisir
Oise elle est dans votre commune et vous
avez signé une convention avec elle
c'est ça quand on a su que voilà on
avait cette jeune fille à plaisir et
bien on a signé une convention avec elle
pour la compagnie financièrement à
hauteur de 1000 euros sur trois années
puisque on voulait l'accompagner
jusqu'aux Jeux Olympiques en pariant sur
elle et on l'a rencontré à l'hôtel de
ville elle est vraiment charmante et on
sent qu'elle est très impliquée on est
très fière d'elle et on la suit on
espère en tout cas qu'elle ira aux Jeux
olympiques de Paris 24 vraiment on
poursuit cette page sport on va parler
de la Piscia case coureur cycliste ou
randonneuse sont tous donnés rendez-vous
dimanche dernier à la pissia caisse dans
le domaine forestier de Poissy la course
a réuni 2000 participants pour cette
édition 2023 Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
et Julien Leroy ont suivi les coureurs
du parcours de 10 km
ambiance survolter pour cette onzième
édition de la pissiaque dans le domaine
forestier de Poissy ce dimanche 16 avril
plus de 850 sportifs ont participé à la
course phare des 10 km un parcours
emblématique entre ville et nature c'est
vraiment une très très bonne ambiance
c'est très sympathique et voilà c'est
très convivial c'est la fête du sport
qui est pas loin de chez moi et on est
là pour s'amuser on va chercher un petit
peu de vitesse mais plaisir avant tout
moi c'est mon être motiv plaisir moment
de détente pour certains et esprit de
compétition pour d'autres par contre on
le connaît par cœur parce que c'est nos
routes d'entraînement donc on s'entraîne
deux trois quatre fois la semaine ici et
c'est un parcours qui est ludique avec
un peu dénivelé un peu de ville à défis
également de finir la course également
pourquoi pas aller sur les 40 minutes
au terme de cette course de 10 km
d'Orient conenx issu du club Poissy
triathlon remporte la victoire sous les
acclamations des spectateurs un moment
de partage avec ses amis et un bon
entraînement physique j'ai un tous les
ans depuis 8 ou 9 ans maintenant ça
s'est joué jusqu'à la fin donc j'ai dû
vraiment puiser pour battre Aurélien qui
s'est pas laissé faire des courses 1,5
et 5 km des épreuves de Bike and Run
ainsi qu'une randonnée était aussi au
programme de cette pisiaque au total
plus de 2000 participants ont répondu
présent pour cette édition 2023
et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
je vous propose de jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
le printemps et le soleil reviennent
dans les Yvelines demain matin le ciel
sera dégagé sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera 10 degrés en moyenne dans
l'après-midi le soleil continuera de
briller et le thermomètre va encore
monter il fera 18 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Rambouillet
et 17 degrés dans le secteur de
Versailles voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de votre fidélité demain
vous retrouverez Grégory canalet à la
présentation nous serons en édition
spéciale au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
l'agglomération organise un événement
pour les entreprises les étudiants et
toutes celles et ceux qui veulent
booster leurs opportunités en attendant
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV
78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]